[Müzik]
hepiniz hoş geldiniz Bu güzel günü
küçük mini bir müzik performansıyla
çiçeklendirmeye geldim
[Müzik]
Pencereme
şarkı kalbim Ruhumda Dans etmişsin
olmasa da olur diyorum zor şeyler
düşünemiyorum azalır geçer sonunda biter
biliyorum
hayat
[Müzik]
oyuncağını Sen Rüzgarları
[Alkış]
başlamak için sebep bu sana şans ver
Geçmişi unut
Aldırmaz sana
bol Rıza kay
Ar yeter sana
zaman mum gibi
[Müzik]
için sebep bu sana şans ver
geçmişi
Aldırmaz sana
burcuma
yeter sana zaman zaman mum gibi
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
pencereme
bir şarkı kalbim ruhumla dans etsin
olmasa da olur diyorum zor şeyler
düşlemiyorum azalır geçer sonunda biter
biliyorum
Senin de vardır elbet
hayal
i oyuncağını
kıran askerleri
[Müzik]
başlamak için sebep bu sana
ver Geçmişi unut
aldığıma sana
bu çok hayal
yeter sana zaman mum gibi
[Müzik]
bu sana şans ver geçmişi
aldırma sana
bu çok beyaz
yeter sana zaman zaman mum gibi
eriyorsun sonunda
Çok teşekkürler
Şimdi ikinci şarkının ismi mutluluk
çizdim resmini
dileğimi Hayalimin Şimdi ben gökyüzüne
bakıyorum
mutluluğun tarifi işte hayatı tüm
le yaşayabilir
Hadi Senle şeyleri düşün
elim Aç kollarını Çiçeklerim
Nasıl olsa buluruz yavrumuzu
kayboluruz
[Müzik]
bazen her karanlık
Hadi Senle şeyleri düşün
Aç kollarını çiçeklen
elim Nasıl olsa buluruz
[Müzik]
kayboluruz bazen ama Güneş
[Alkış]
doğar
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
bir resmini
hayal edin Şimdi ben gökyüzüne bakıyorum
[Müzik]
mutluluğun tarifi işte hayatı tüm
renkleriyle görebiliyorum
yaşayabiliyor
Hadi Senle şeyleri
düşünelim
ağaç kollarını çiçeklerini
Nasıl olsa buluruz Yolumuz
[Alkış]
u
kayboluruz bazen ama Güneş doğ
[Müzik]
Ar Hadi Senle şeyleri düşün
elim Aç kollarını çiçeklenelim
Nasıl olsa buluruz
kaybolur
olmaz
sa güneş doğar
hep
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
durur mu Dünya Döner kiminin yangın
söner kimi anlam çoğaltır kimi anlam
gömer Su akar Deniz ile kavuşur Deniz
okyanusuyla buluşur değişir Her şey
değişir
dayanmadı Soner bizi de dövsün hayat
bizi de yorsun varsın
[Müzik]
geciktirirler ancak durduramazlar
gelecek Akar zaman
korkan yerinde saysın bütün boşluklara
sızlar
bıkmadan
yaşlanırken yaşlanmadan taş tutmadan yas
tutmadan
eğilmeden bükülmeden
ezmeden ezilmeden kim tutmadan kül
yutmadan dev bu Tempo tem
Pool
[Müzik]
bizi de dövsün hayat
bizi de yorsun varsın
geciktirilen durduramazlar
geleceği Akar zaman
korkan yerinde saysın bütün boşluklara
sızlar
Bıkmadan
usanmadan yaşlanırken yaşlanmadan pas
tutmadan yaz tutmadan
eğilmeden bükülmeden esmeden esilmeden
kim tutmadan Kül yutmadan
[Müzik]
Dead
Pool
[Müzik]
Yağmur Sonrası Umut'un gökkuşağı
kalbini boya rengarenk
izle Onu gayret Parla çoğaldı
cesaretlen
[Müzik]
di bayan çiz resmini pembe
sır sınırsız
kişinin rengine boyan çiz resmini pembe
sarı mavi bile değil gibi sınırsız
[Müzik]
Sen de seversen
kendinle hepimize kimseyi aldırmadan yol
a
[Müzik]
bilsen kimseyi aldırmadan yol
a
Dilediğin gibi sınırsız
[Müzik]
düşünün rengine boyan çiz resmini pembe
sarı mavi Dilediğin gibi
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
düşünüzün dişinizin rengine boyandınız
çok güzel günler olsun Görüşmek üzere
hoşça kalın
[Alkış]